mate it was just it was an added
opportunity I could not miss like this
he he put that ad out in the paper in
the gum tree and I was like when I read
that that was absolutely shuttering I
was like imagine because I come from a
family of four brothers I'm like imagine
if we were all in the car one day going
up north which we do all the time for
fishing and something happened to us and
I was like no way what would happen to
my old man or what how would he go
fishing it and things like that even
though my old man has heaps of people to
go fishing with but just to put myself
into his shoes and it just was
heartbreaking
so I made the offer out there to fly him
up from South Australia which is a
another state in Australia and I'm in
Queensland so which is quite far so I
made an offer to pay for his tickets to
head over and also pay for his
accommodation and bring him into an
aisle and a beautiful island in
Queensland called strawberry god it was
not there was no money there was no
dollar signs on this at all it was just
all about helping him out and getting
him here to put a smile on his face and
the joy of seeing a smile on his face
has just mind-blowing literally brings
tears to my eyes I saw him he's never
caught a plane in his life ever so just
the fact to get him out of hit out of
South Australia to get him to Queensland
over to me was that was one thing that's
a that's a major step in his life just
to get on a plane he's got 75 years old
he has never caught a plane in his life
so it just was unreal the things he's
doing now is just looking at him he's
quite quiet because he's never seen
these some of these things before and if
he has he's seen in many many years ago
so it's he's probably feeling a little
bit younger
he's probably put a few kilos on to
because we're feeding him quite well so
and we've been having a ball we've been
here for three two days now we're
leaving tomorrow and he's had some
fishing we've done some formal driving
we've done sightseeing he's been on the
beach he's had a great time on though
it's been awesome things more of the old
school tips though we've moved on in the
engineering side of the fishing world
that he's taught me a few chips and he's
got the wisdom on me he's taught me not
just fishing he's taught me some life
girls he's taught me the biggest thing
out of all this is to appreciate all
this like I do this all the time and I
lost the I lost the appreciation for the
value for it
it got to a point where I was doing this
on dormice these trips not just a
strawberry garden and all various arms
around Queensland and
I did not I lost the appreciation for it
and his he's here now with me and he's
being like the love for this on the
passion Freud has just brought it back
out to me to not take advantage of it of
the Orleans and and what this place has
to offer and she's been great it's just
been unreal we've obviously exchanged
numbers and all that but if we're
already talking about me flying down to
Adelaide where he is in South Australia
and already organizing a next trip it
shouldn't have had to take this and add
in the Gumtree to get to get a mate it
shouldn't have to go that way there
should be something out there where
everyone can be connected somehow or an
app or anything where we can find bodies
to go fishing with and let this be an
example for everyone where we shouldn't
have to have to put ads up there there
should be people out there to be able to
go fishing with any day the way whenever
you want